>> Jason: EARLIER TODAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP VETOED THE
NATIONAL DEFENSE AUTHORIZATION
ACT, FOLLOWING THROUGH ON HIS
PROMISE TO VETO THE BILL IF
CONGRESS DIDN’T STRIP AWAY
LIABILITY PROTECTIONS FOR BIG
TECH.
WE ARE LEARNING MORE TONIGHT
ABOUT THE MASSIVE SOLAR WINDS
CYBER HACK ON MULTIPLE FEDERAL
AGENCIES.
ALSO TONIGHT COME OF THE ROGUE
IRANIAN REGIME IS CONTINUING TO
FUELED VIOLENCE AND STOKE
TENSIONS ACROSS THE MIDDLE EAST
PROMPTING PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
TWEET EARLIER TODAY OUR EMBASSY
IN BAGHDAD GOT HIT SUNDAY BY
SEVERAL ROCKETS.
GUESS WHERE THEY WERE FROM, IRAN
IRAN.
NOW WE HEAR CHATTER OF
ADDITIONAL ATTACKS AGAINST
AMERICANS IN IRAQ, SOME FRIENDLY
HEALTHY ADVICE TO IRAN, IF ONE
AMERICAN IS KILLED, I WILL HOLD
IRAN RESPONSIBLE.
THINK IT OVER.
JOINING ME NOW FOR INSIGHT,
AMBASSADOR ROBERT O’BRIEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
COME I WANT TO GO FIRST TO IRAN,
GIVE US THE LATEST ON THAT
SITUATION.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON ON THE BYU
COUGARS AND THE BIG WIN LAST
NIGHT, I KNOW YOU ARE FOLLOWING
THE WHOLE SEASON CLOSELY.
THE SITUATION IS NO DIFFERENT
THAN IT HAS BEEN IN MANY YEARS,
THE IRANIAN REGIME IS TRYING TO
DRIVE THE UNITED STATES OUT OF
OUR ALLIANCES COME OUT OF OUR
PARTNERSHIPS AND POSITION IN THE
MIDDLE EAST WITH OUR FRIENDS AND
ALLIES.
THEY ARE USING PROXIES TO DO IT.
IN A RACK THEY USING HAS LAW AND
OTHER GROUPS, THEY ARE EXECUTING
ATTACKS AGAINST THE EMBASSY AND
OTHER FACILITIES.
THE PRESIDENT MADE IT CLEAR THAT
IF AN AMERICAN IS KILLED, THAT
IS A REDLINE FOR US AND IRAN
WILL BEAR THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
US.
HE SENT A STRONG MESSAGE TODAY
AND IF I WERE THE IRANIANS I
WOULD HEED THAT MESSAGE.
I THINK IT WOULD BE FOOLISH TO
TEST HIS WILL ON THIS ISSUE.
>> Jason: I’VE GOT TO MOVE ON
TO THE HACK FOR THE ATTACK ON
OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, I THINK
THERE HAS BEEN A CYBER WAR GOING
ON FOR YEARS, WHO WAS AT, WHO
WAS RESPONSIBLE, AND WHAT CAN
THE UNITED STATES DO TO FIGHT
BACK?
>> WE ARE UNDERTAKING A MASSIVE
INVESTIGATION OF THE INCIDENT,
CLEARLY A SOPHISTICATED
INTELLIGENCE OPERATION.
WILL NOT GET AROUND TO
ATTRIBUTION AT A TIME AND PLACE
OF OUR CHOOSING.
WE ARE MITIGATING THE PROBLEM
AND MAKING SURE THAT OUR
NETWORKS ARE SAFE AND THAT THE
MALWARE AND BACKDOORS ARE BEING
CLOSED.
DURING THIS CHRISTMAS SEASON, I
WANT TO THANK THE FRONT-LINE
WORKERS IN THIS CYBER WAR, THE
FOLKS IN THE FBI, DNI, NSA, DHS
THAT HAVE LITERALLY BEEN WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK SINCE THIS
BREACH WAS DISCOVERED TO KEEP US
SAFE AND PROTECT OUR NETWORKS
AND TO EXPEL THIS SOFTWARE AND
CODE THAT IS NOW IN THE SYSTEM.
THEY ARE DOING A GREAT JOB WHILE
WE ARE CELEBRATING THE HOLIDAYS,
THEY’RE WORKING 24/7.
I WANT TO PASS ON THE PRESIDENTS
THANKS TO THEM AND MY THANKS AS
WELL.
>> Jason: I STUDIED THIS WHEN
I WAS IN CONGRESS, THE
UNITED STATES IS CONSTANTLY
UNDER ATTACK.
IT’S HARD TO GET THE TALENT WE
NEED IN ORDER TO PROTECT AGAINST
THOSE THREATS, EVERYTHING FROM A
GUY IN A VAN DOWN BY THE RIVER
AND THESE NATION-STATES COMING
AFTER US.
I WANT TO MOVE, WE’VE GOT TO GET
TO THE SUBJECT OF THE NATIONAL
DEFENSE AUTHORIZATION ACT, HE’D
BE TOWED IT TODAY.
WHAT DOES HE WANT TO SEE CHANGED
IN ORDER TO GET IT SIGNED?
>> ONE THING I WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR IS WHEN THE PRESIDENT TOOK
OFFICE HE INHERITED A MILITARY
WITH THE READINESS WAS THE WORST
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
WE WERE OUT OF AMMUNITION, WE
HAD THE LOWEST SHIP COUNT EVER
COME OF THE MILITARY HAD
SUFFERED THROUGH EIGHT YEARS OF
SEQUESTRATION.
HE TURNED THAT AROUND AND SPENT
TWO AND A HALF TRILLION DOLLARS
REBUILDING THE MILITARY -- THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN COMMITTED TO
A STRONG NATIONAL DEFENSE, THIS
BILL DIDN’T INCLUDE THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE NECESSARY,
OUR ADVERSARIES ARE USING TO
PROMOTE THIS INFORMATION ON
TWITTER AND FACEBOOK AND OTHER
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS, WE GOT
TO GET THAT WERE FORMED TO
PROTECT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE PRESIDENT CAMPAIGNED ON
ENDING FOREVER WARS, HE HAS
DRAWN DOWN TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN
AND IRAQ AND WE CAN REDEPLOY
THOSE TROOPS TO THE FRONT LINES
IN EASTERN EUROPE TO PROTECT
AMERICAN INTERESTS, THE SAME
ONES THAT HAVE HAD US UNDER
ATTACK, CYBER AND OTHERWISE FOR
MANY YEARS.
THIS BILL PURPORTS TO TAKE AWAY
HIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, DEPLOY OUR
ARMED FORCES IN THE SAME THING
GOES TO GERMANY, WE WANT TO MOVE
TROOPS OUT OF THESE BASES AND
PUT THEM INTO FRONT LINE
POSITIONS TO DETER OUR
ADVERSARIES AND PROTECT OUR
FRIENDS.
IT WAS CONSTITUTIONALLY SUSPECT
AND LASTLY IT GETS INTO CULTURE
WARS THAT REALLY SHOULDN’T BE
DEBATED, THERE MAY BE A
LEGITIMATE DEBATE THERE BUT THE
MILITARY SHOULDN’T BE HELD
HOSTAGE.
THE PRESIDENT DIDN’T THINK IT
WAS THE RIGHT BILL, HE WANTS
STRONG DEFENSE AND JUST
SUBMITTED A NAVY SHIPBUILDING
PLAN THAT IS PAID FOR FOR MANY
YEARS IN PART BECAUSE WE ARE
DRAWING DOWN AND WRAPPING UP
SOME OF THESE FOREVER WARS.
HE’S GOT A GREAT RECORD ON
DEFENSE AND IS PROUD OF IT AND
HE WANTS A CLEAN BILL TO COME
BACK FROM CONGRESS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
>> Jason: NOBODY WILL CHEER
HIM ON MORE THAN MYSELF IN TERMS
OF BRINGING OUR TROOPS HOME FROM
THESE ENDLESS WARS.
WE OUGHT TO CELEBRATE BRINGING
OUR TROOPS HOME, IT’S AMAZING TO
ME HOW MANY PEOPLE JUST WANT
THEM TO STAY THERE IN
PERPETUITY.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
LISTENING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND BRING THOSE TROOPS HOME AND
HE NEEDS THE FLEXIBILITY AS
PRESIDENT TO DO SO.
I GOT END ON CHINA.
DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE MORE FROM
MY VANTAGE POINT TO PUSH BACK
AND HIGHLIGHT CHINA AND LOOK AT
WHAT THEY ARE DOING ON SO MANY
FRONTS.
WALK US THROUGH THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO IN CHINA,
I’VE ONLY GOT ABOUT 40 SECONDS.
>> THEY HOLLOWED OUT OUR
MANUFACTURING BY STEALING OUR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY AND
SUBSIDIZING THE STATE OWNED
ENTERPRISES AND BUYING OUR
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES.
THE PRESENT PUT ON TARIFFS, GOT
A GREAT PHASE ONE TRADE DEAL --
THEY EXTINGUISHED FREEDOM IN
HONG KONG, THEY ARE ENGAGED IN
TERRIBLE ACTIVITIES WITH THE
UIGHURS AND ENJOYING STOMACH
DESTROYING RELIGIOUS FREEDOM,
THEY TOOK OVER THE ENTIRE SOUTH
CHINA SEA IT LIKE IT’S SOME SORT
OF DOMESTIC LAKE AND WE STOOD UP
TO THEM, WE STOOD UP TO THEM
ACROSS THE BOARD.
THEY WERE TAKING OVER THE WORLD
WITH 5G SO THEY COULD CONTROL
ALL OF OUR DATA, THE PRESIDENT
STOPPED THAT AND NOW MOST OF OUR
ALLIES ARE GOING TO HAVE CLEAN
NETWORKS AND ARE EXPELLING THEM
FROM OUR 5G NETWORKS, DATA
PRIVACY AND PROTECTING NATIONAL
SECURITY, WHAT HE HAS DONE ON
CHINA, HE SHOWED THAN WE CAN
WIN.
I THINK THERE WERE A LOT OF
DEFEATISTS WHO BELIEVED YOU
COULD NEVER STAND UP TO CHINA,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SHOULD WE COULD STAND UP
TO CHINA AND WIN.
>> Jason: AMBASSADOR ROBERT
O’BRIEN, MANY THANKS TO YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY, YOUR WORK
EXCEPTIONALLY HARD AS DOES YOUR
STAFF POURING YOUR HEART AND
SOUL INTO IT, THANK YOU FOR YOUR